there is a story right now
of one of the worst
serial killers i've ever heard about in
american history
the
that the trial just was going on just
within the last couple of weeks and you
probably haven't heard about it
this this is billy chemermere
billy chemermere
is uh he looks like kind of like a
middle-aged guy
middle-aged a little bit younger he's an
immigrant from kenya he became a
permanent u.s resident in 2007.
billy chemermere was arrested in march
of 2018
after a 91 year old woman mary annis
bartel said that a man forced his way
into her apartment at an independent
living community for older people in in
the dallas suburb of plano and tried to
and attacked her and tried to steal her
stuff
and then the authorities
looked into this guy and he had a ton of
jewelry and cash and
they linked him
to the murders of 18
old women
18 women
in their 80s in their 90s he would break
into their homes
murder them
and steal their jewelry and their money
we've got at least 18 here the evidence
is
overwhelming that this guy did it
there is there is no way to look at the
evidence
at even a tenth of the evidence and say
this guy didn't do it
but there's a mistrial because 11 jurors
said it's obviously the case and then
there's one juror who said no one in
transit ginger whether this was jury
nullification or this was a political
activist or something but they wouldn't
do it
so it's a mistrial this guy looks like
he's just going to get off the hook for
murdering 18 old women in cold blood and
stealing their jewels
and
probably the even greater scandal than
that is that you're not going to hear
about it because this doesn't go along
with the media narrative potentially one
of the worst serial killers in american
history
may well get off the hook because of a
mistrial because of a hung jury because
one juror is
seems to be holding out again we just we
don't know we don't have totally solid
reports on obviously exactly what's
going on in the jury room
but overwhelming evidence that this guy
murdered 18 old women and stole their
stuff
and but one juror for whatever reason
doesn't want to convict
and you haven't heard about it whatever
the jury is dealing with whatever the
what's going on in the trial you haven't
heard about it why because
it contradicts the media narrative the
guy who did it was black not white
but according to the media narrative
all black people good all white people
bad
black lives matter is the greatest most
wonderful peaceful organization in the
world even though they burned the
country down for eight months and killed
dozens of people
but if white people
do anything
anything that is in any way questionable
it's really bad you know the lor it
wasn't just white people but it was
there were a lot of white people at the
capitol hill
incident on january 6 and that's being
called the worst terrorist attack in
history so the black and white thing
that doesn't work he's an immigrant
but immigrants good native born
americans bad so that
that doesn't work out very well at all
and
so they're not going to talk about it
they're not going to talk about this
sort of thing
that is a scandal
and we need to see and what what's going
on with this jury we have no idea 18
older women
your grandmother think of your
grandmother murdered in cold blood for
some jewels
a dozen and a half
times
how would i say that one and a half
dozen times i don't know 18 times we're
talking about
not a peep
not a peep because of the racial
narratives of the left largely i think
and the immigrant narratives and the
broader political narratives did you
like that clip be honest i can take it i
did you well if you did
even if you didn't please subscribe ring
that bell get the notifications for when
i have new videos out
and if you really want to get the
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast type
in the michael knowles show boom
subscribe
boom five star review boom
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you